sebastian dueling joins us today he's an
economist and professor at the HTW
university of applied sciences here in
Berlin it's good to have you with us and
of course you've been following all
these debt negotiations what's your
impression of these very last talks this
week I mean finally the two sides are
moving closer together and we now have a
real chance to come to a compromise at
least for for this time being and for
the last tranche of the second rescue
package okay you say there's a real
chance only recently the head of the
International Monetary Fund christine
lagarde said that Ukraine is more
creditworthy than Greece that doesn't
really bode well does it I mean Ukraine
has a debt to GDP ratio of maybe ninety
percent Greece had one has one of
hundred seventy percent so well the dead
level of Ukraine is lower than that of
Greece and it's very very clear that
without New eight Greece will not be
able to repay its debt so I guess you
can say it's more creditworthy than
Ukraine even though Ukraine's at the
brink of bankruptcy itself but it
certainly will take a look a lot of good
will on both sides and right now Greek
savers they continued to withdraw large
volumes of money from Greek banks the
european central bank has approved more
emergency funds for greek banks does
this mean that whatever happens the ECB
will keep the country rolling no I mean
at one point the ECB might not continue
to do so because legally the ECB can
give emergency aid if the bank has good
collateral good collateral means for
example government bound bonds which
which are serviced if the government
stops paying interest rates on the bonds
then it's not good collateral anymore
and then the ECB cannot give more h to
greek banks and that would be the end of
the Greek banking sector now let's say
all goes well this week at least and
Greece will get by the end of the months
those 7.2 billion euros that's just
about enough in order to pay the IMF and
the EC back over the next two months
well then I mean this is true we are
just talking about the last tranche of
the second eight package and this will
not be the end we already know that in
the second
of the year there will be more payments
for the big governments to be done and
then the government needs more aid in
order to to repay its creditors and of
course we've been there before Sebastian
Dooley don't go anywhere because we will
continue this little chat back to our
studio guest now Sebastian dueling from
the HTW university of applied sciences
in berlin and what you've just seen
there is that austerity hasn't really
reduced Greece's huge mountain of debt
it's actually increased it in a certain
way so why do creditors then insist on
more austerity on more cuts I mean the
first point is if you do not do
austerity you need to give more money up
front and you never know whether they
will repay it in the end so they wanted
to have this this kind of policy because
this would limit what what they need to
put on the table at the beginning but it
is obviously not a solution we I mean
clearly austerity has been a failure and
the the main result has been that the
Greek economy has shrunk by almost
twenty-five percent over the past years
and this is becoming more and more clear
but I mean they isn't an easy way out
because if you want to stop austerity
you need to get the money to spend from
someplace and well bcp isn't going to
just print it the greek Finance Minister
Yanis varoufakis recently said that
Athens doesn't actually want more money
from its creditors but a haircut or if
you like a kind of forgiveness for the
enormous debt would that be a way out
yeah i mean i think a haircut on the
debt would be one of the preconditions
for the Greek economy to return to debt
because sorry not to be shown to death
but to the Donati hopefully not but to
return to growth because at the moment
Greece is just borrowing money in order
to repay old debt so they are not
borrowing money to spend so if this debt
would be reduced they would have room to
maneuver elsewhere and then they could
actually produce growth something that
is desperately needed I mean what else
can do grease right now in order to
produce gross because otherwise we'll be
revisiting the situation again and again
yeah frankly I believe without debt
relief Greece can do
little because just because this debt
burden is their private investors would
be very reluctant to invest in Greece
because I mean there will always be the
debate can grease pay it and there's
always nationalization expropriation and
so on on the horizon yeah eventually
they won't be able to sell anything
anymore anyway now there are some
experts of course who say that the best
thing for Greece and they don't mean it
in a bad way would be to say all right
this didn't work out for us in the euro
let's leave the euro let's introduce our
own currency whatever we shall call it
and then we can start in you I mean the
problem with this argument is that it
would badly damaged the European project
and the Euro itself it would show
markets that the year is not irrevocable
and my fear would be that we might have
capital outflows from Spain and Italy
and this might bring down the whole
European project in the future that's of
course exactly what those who are in
favor of a grexit also argue that Greece
keeping in the euro at all costs
jeopardizes the euro I mean yes of
course this is the argument from the
other side but you need to keep it in
perspective I mean even the huge Greek
rescue packages they are nothing
compared to Italy's debt and Italy is
just too big to fail on a global scale
for the global financial system all
right well Sebastian Dooley I fear that
the discussion will go on but not here
right now thank you very much for your
time thank you very much for the
invitation